c'est lui la star du cirque de noël lui
qui fait le clown par tradition
familiale depuis qu'il a 6 ans car vingt
trois ans sur scène à ferrer ou et me
voir fait rire sans un mot et c'est là
tout son talent
[Applaudissements]
base de cloud traditionnels donc à
partir des chats je travaillais beaucoup
d'autres choses
une des choses que j'ai travaillé
beaucoup c'est me faire comprendre par
totalement 200 dirhams en fait y'a pas
besoin gestuellement je m'explique très
bien
eux aussi ne prononce pas amour ils sont
russes viennent de moscou danse le tango
à merveille et pour les accompagner des
danseurs d'un autre genre tout aussi
talentueux
[Musique]
moi je les connaissais pas du tout quand
j'ai découvert ce numéro là tu es en
janvier février
moi ce qui m'a vraiment plu c'est ce
mélange des animaux et surtout ce
n'était pas juste on entre avec un chien
ou avec un chat et on lui fait faire
quelque chose il ya toute une mise en
scène avec une danse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque année on vient et c'est vraiment
super on aime bien venu justement
famille après au moment des fêtes
ça fait continuer un petit peu les fêtes
et c'est vraiment super c'est la magie
c'est tous les enfants on aime les voir
rigoler tout c'est un tout c'est super
les gary locke ne de pas mal
[Applaudissements]
vous serez pas qu'on travaille il ya
beaucoup de travail
le cerceau et la dame toute brillante
qui fait la toupie
on est admiratif avait une forte dans
les jambes entre numéros aériens show de
dextérité dressage d'animaux pendant
deux heures de spectacle près de 22
nationalités vont se succéder
un melting-pot qui nous aura fait
sourire ému et voyager la magie du
cirque